l'année suivante les quatre jeanne
enfants
indigné
pendant un stage de trois mois
et en pharmacie alex-hechler
ap
pour moi avec les accès pour cent et 6
5% c'est donc en france
hélas non
trois fois plus grand que la france pour
neuf fois moins d'habitants le québec
est la plus vaste des dix provinces du
canada
premier producteur mondial
d'hydroélectricité à la 6e place pour
le pétrole deux tiers de ces échanges
se font avec les etats-unis
me sens à l'aise avec sarkozy vincent
les cabanes en bois
que ce soit des rallyes
mais aussi sa place
menés en juillet et en août
80% des quelque 8 millions de
québécois sont francophones la belle
province l'un des bastions de la langue
française son combat contre
l'anglicisation
a fait date dans les mouvements de la
francophonie le premier ministre jean
charest est l'organisateur du forum
mondial de la langue française en 2012
cette fois on écrit m
m6 music ally et clémentine sont toutes
les trois en formation à lille pour
être éducatrice jeunes enfants elle
s'apprête à partir pour trois mois en
stage au québec elle compte bien tester
l'accueil légendaire des québécois
et profiter de la richesse de la nature
90 alors pourquoi ce voyage en europe au
québec qu'est-ce qui vous pousse à
aller au québec il sera enfin pour
découvrir ces pays de sierentz
avancées au niveau de la petite enfance
donc c'est pour ça que c'est très
intéressant car là-bas trois mois
ça laisse le temps de réaliser que
c'est vrai
de voyager découvrez québec et on va
essayer de les aider à préparer ce
voyage en répondant à vos questions
m a priori comme ça à ce que vous avez
déjà des interrogations obama vient de
se savoir comment ça fonctionne
l'ajustement s'est fait élire pourquoi
une province française
simple cerné par des millions
d'européens
comme tous
les fédéralistes monde
quel type de décision relève de
desquels elle apporte un soutien très
bas du canada tout entier
si l'ensemble
quels sont les différents
il invite à regarder
pour répondre aux questions de
voyageurs sur l'histoire du québec et
sa place dans la confédération
canadienne
nous allons rencontrer jacques fortier
il est professeur d'histoire
dix ans à paris
tous
pendant sa cavale de l'automne
à l'arena en voyage réservé à
connaître un peu l'histoire de ce pays
comment croire comme ça francophone
sert à trouver
millions 900 mille fans absolument oui
et par jacques cartier c'est le premier
été découvert entre le 10 mai et 14 h
g
mais il est pratiquement un siècle
entre jacques cartier et la façon de
québec se sont vite n'ayant pas trouvé
de milliers de métaux précieux myriam
base ne pas tirer trop
il a fallu attendre
donc le début du succès que pour de
nouveaux dirigeants qui voulaient
d'accepter de de partir là-bas à quoi
touché à changer avec l'indépendance
américaine
quand les etats-unis deviennent
indépendants ça va provoquer
à ce moment-là un afflux d'emblée
aussi bien le territoire noël france
que dans d'autres parties du canada
avant il avait très peu il est resté
une concurrence alors entre eux les
anglophones et les francophones
et oui c'est dire que là et elle la
province de québec le livre de québec
par an
après la confédération n'était
callum du second set
a été le refuge des canadiens
français doit d'abord aurait de quoi
et qui ont des acquis ont cultivé leur
identité l'identité donc été
française et catholiques pour
l'essentiel
un début d ormuz avant la
confédération sauver des vies nous
allier les collégiens français dessous
la mas anglophones sont
et quand elle réussit alors à
préserver l'alliance réussie parce que
j'avais une abeille de très fortes
parce que si ce sont enfermés ce papa
enfermé dans sa vie se sont
développées à une entité propre
à ce que le français l alhambra
professionnel n'a rien d'officielle ya
une énorme poussée de dubaï peu plus
contesté par certains aspects
elles brillent les étoiles que revoyez
c'est le depuis son de 17 c'est la
langue même charte de la langue
française
et quand les a les élus et les
policiers anglais dont nous sommes sûrs
de ce qu'ils ne pouvaient pas
être majoritaire finalement
ils sont arrivés à faire des compromis
sans arrêt entre l'école français et
les anglais qui ont abouti à la
confédération bush a grassement et je
sois plus à toulouse ils ont gardé ce
côté là
debout jusqu'au années 60
dans le cas de la confédération
en développant toujours s'empêche de
d'identité un peu retardataires par son
côté un peu rencontre le progrès
la marque par l'église catholique à
tout cela
et donc tout sauf aisé de même la
banque de rhodes retard relatif du
québec on m a éclaté
à partir des années 60
ce vote est l'expression qui a été
ensuite imité en france la révolution
tranquille
et c'était là l'idée donc on pouvait
faire une révolution en ce sens de sang
le sang la force - et sans violence
la république violences notamment peu
de choses comme très marginal
et donc là il ya eu un effort de
modernisation incontestable
québec une nation culturelle but
des gens comme charlebois com
prise de terre et autres
littéraire avec des auteurs nouveau le
break terres de l'élite de demain comme
ça
et politique aussi puisqu'il s'est agit
de renforcer l'état du québec
et d'en faire une demain de 8 heures
à partir des années 60
avec l'aide de la france pour essayer
qui a accepté d'aider après de bonnes
photos à présent de cette année ses
débuts des maximums développement du
québec
comme les torts parce que le pari de
voler des films indépendants
philippe séguin évidemment de sa femme
israélienne au québec il revient sur
m6 a séduit les hommes 7
au site
qui sait
pourquoi
alors
ce n'est plus pareil
lui veut du jeu
quelle allure
les plus grands airs
plus le lâcher
nulle
et ça ça et ça et des biens sur la
place et pas tellement le québécois
eux-mêmes de cette belle sur la carte
du monde enfin fate exister
et justement mouvement indépendantiste
cas et les tentations 1% quels en sont
les mamies des attentats avaient marre
aujourd'hui % en un an et demi les
référendums plusieurs doubles pour
l'indépendance et qui voyez pour chaque
fois
à 21 h
elle les invite à participer à ce
qu'elle pourra politique mais le
problème c'est ça c'est que
le modèle les paul était comme
fondées
sur l'idée de vendre du québec mais en
même temps % et 800 communes dans la
perspective d'un référendum s'éloigne
le parti québécois en lui-même pr une
part de son identité qu'est-ce-qu'il
des faits pourquoi bien toujours
une très forte personnalité
toutefois on ne peut pas changer
mais pour cent aussi le dénoncer à
quoi ça sert d'aller plus loin
il n'empêche pas que le débat ne se
plaindra
grâce en partie aux
patti lupone 76 à 1 91 15 de ça
tara quand même
balisé son identité incontestablement
mais enfin ils sont quand même
situation qui est toujours un petit peu
en importe billy may par rapport aux
cabanes sont ils sont pas ils sont
dedans sans las vegas je sors pour
comprendre comment marche un peu
sévère à luzenac canadien
parce que ce qui intéresse nos voyages
s est pas exempt de tout ce qui concerne
les lois sociales et l'intervention sur
la petite enfance c'est en partage
amelia torres dans l'éducation des
enfants cette idée décision à l'aller
les prix au niveau du gouvernement du
québec pour
en ce sens des lois canadiennes en cd
sans se sont essentiellement tous les
domaines de l'éducation
des lois sociales des services sociaux
s'est strictement provincial
deux fois le poteau droit de lloris dès
maintenant sur une scène ce ne sont pas
ces questions
ainsi on peut la croire
situé à taux plein
il ya un
du coup je me ces petits centres
ne vous inquiétez pas
pagesjaunes groupe
nombreux sont les nuits des 25 et 26 ans
mon quartier
à l'attaqué
vous êtes sensible au fait que le
québec fait partie d'un le mouvement de
défense de la francophonie
je pense que c'est important mais de
de soutenir son plan et attend ça prend
le pas un peu partout à travers le
monde
et de se dire que derrière ça persiste
dans certaines
dans certains pays
on a envie que ça continue
au québec la langue jouera un rôle
primordial puisque les québécois qui
sont francophones sont concernés par le
vih
au bord de la faillite
et l'un des meilleurs outils de défense
de la langue française c'est la chanson
on va rencontrer maintenant une star de
la chanson québécoise coeur de pirate
est en concert en france
vos joueurs
le français est la langue française
pour vous inscrire
qu'est-ce que ça représente
air france est assez leur enquête qui
malheureusement a elle n'est plus
parlée beaucoup c'est dommage parce que
c'est un très très très belle et par
farhat rajhi a comme stable
des appareils et dim
édifié dans le traitement de texte par
les français elle est d'air france par
moment au stadium plein à 60 ans - bl
je pense qu'elle est absente un petit
peu mal à rester on voit que l'amendé
elle survient le fais mais je pense
qu'elle a toujours contesté
la baisse afin d'avoir la défense
allemande née à l'afp afin notamment
grâce à la chanson c'est l'une des
armes c'est beaucoup pour votre destin
en proie à la contestation c'est ce qui
est en général et
allez un sujet était tabou entre les
français et les québécois ces vaccins
nous on trouve que vous en avez à vous
vous trouvez que nos morts
pour ce que c'est non pas comme il faut
la recette est acceptable
je sais pas apparemment c'est pas mal
soignée en carrière cela n'a rien à
voir mais elle s'engage pour m pourtant
je pars à l'étranger
un an mais ont vaillamment comme mon
hareng à la sarre vous vous attendez à
taussat vaccin n'est pas terre
la fin d'une ère
tokyo va être ouvert et larissa
à la place qu'il faut est-ce que vous
avez quelques expressions typiques à
québec on estime à l'esprit
voyant le magazine et ils m'ont mise
pierre
elle a réalisé 23 arrêts face à face
à des sénégalais
pas vraiment
pas mal amorcé ma préférée
et je t'aime à un blanc monde
dans la balance des blancs de passer au
canada alors qu'elle est compté
candidat malheureux
c'est comme l'amour à tous
rabaté à l'adolescence a fait là je
parle
et au passage à l'âge adulte
dernièrement une histoire d'amour hors
du coup donc chers comme angers aimé et
dans un contexte c'était plutôt qu'à
passer
pourquoi
et parce que j'avais observé comment
cet espoir s'est forgé une libération
on reste at-il assuré ce que je
préfère c'est quand j'étais ado
j'avais justement face à l'angleterre
claire et calme
ces patchs mc
james social ça c'est l'autre
vous avez un enfant
face à la campagne
pire
lundi
lui-même
mon idole
si djibril cissé
vous avez envie de vous intégrer
pleinement dans la dans la société
québécoise
moi je veux c'est une bonne entrée deux
hommes avaient déjà il ya un an une
approche ans dans leur recherche de
stages ont été avec
les directeurs de structures et % moi
j'étais assez pour
e étonné par course là la
convivialité don divin preuve et le
pire le tutoiement ont-ils
pointe-à-pitre
ça ça vous a préparé oui
un état stable pour le reste de sa vie
avec l image de la société
québécoise et se termine à 1% à
savoir partir on a une image de
montréal avec ses parents et ses
gratte-ciel
cette nature autour et à
moi je les imagine très écolo on se
demande aussi un peu comment les
légendes qui à l'intérieur de cette
ville
pour se fixer l'amérique du nord à ce
que ils sont beaucoup influencé par
heure par l'amérique côté % et le
privé st
ou alors pour fêter un peu plus
européen
voilà comment s'organiser
quant au quotidien
un voyage à travers la france à
s'intégrer dans leur pays d'accueil a
quand même envie de la colocation avec
lui
la société
retour à leur hôtel
totalitaire
on en parle avec mariam la casse
analystes québécoise qui vit à paris
bon j'arrête
amarrée à l'iss en attendant qu'elle
était frappée en passant leur coup de
téléphone par l'accueil qu'elles ont
reçues des québécois
et le tutoiement il n'ya à ce que la
chaleur la légendaire les québécois
est vraiment réel c'est ce qu'on dit à
l'affairé que c'est une des choses
qu'on entend
très régulièrement et surtout de la
part des deux français
il faut que la querelle m
le caractère jovial aux accueillants
d'aidé qui n'est pas un don
passe par autre chose que le tutoiement
fait stresser un peu ps ou parce qu'un
nom tolérante
je voulais toujours de comparer avec la
cité française mais
% et plus tolérante sur
la différence
peut-être moins
dans la matinée
c'est un petit peu moins conformistes
pour ce qui est autorisé par le mariage
gay est autorisée n'est pas clos quels
exemples dans toutes les provinces sauf
que voilà c'était pas trop coûteux
au québec
toutes les religions
pour inspecter plus ou moins même si
parfois ça cause des petites frictions
et ça commence à en causer de plus en
plus mais m
quelque chose que j'ai eu juste du g20
au canada que j'avais jamais vu en
france cet hiver
un policier qui qui partait pour s'en
acquitter seeker et qui portait ses
soutiens dans son attaquant qui portait
pas le château des des policiers qui
pâtit pierre vaneck
et je pense que ça fait quelque chose
contrat jamais voir en france et
justement surtout amant et alquines
ville
trèves multiculturelle très métissée
savoir si les chats communauté symbole
anglaise si c'est très communautaire
aussi ses prix mélanger
belga je pense qu'il a un idéal
de milan je repars quand une vision se
rend compte que malheureusement
% et les communautés vivent souvent au
détours pourquoi les chinois restent
entre eux et parle le chinois dans le
club
c'est difficile finalement d'entrer en
relation avec ces communautaire qui
restent très fermée sur elle-même je
pense qu'il a animé à un peu de
mixité
mais il n'est pas toujours
le vrai monde arabe qui souffre
évidemment les enfants d'immigrés qui
ils sont allés à l'école
en e francophone parce que c'est
obligatoire
et parle le français et ensuite
forcément se mêlent à la population
il a déclaré à l'afp a été pour
cent
plutôt marqué par les images
gratte-ciel un 7 % à montréal le
quotidien a donné l'impression que
c'est pour cent un état très
américanisé
alors est-ce que cette influence
le américaine qui dominerait ce que
c'est l'héritage français
comment ça se passe à deux vitesses
qui
mais une affaire qui prend le pas sur
l'autre
quelques centres intéressants parce que
quand j'étais là-bas
j'étais persuadé que les québécois
étaient heureux
à ces européens ont dans leur manière
de vivre
% mais en fait en vivant en france
depuis dix ans je me rends compte à
quel point c'est une société très
américaine
dans ces valeurs en e
dans ce groupe dans le temps dans son
économie non dans sa politique et même
de plus en plus sûres
donc
est-ce que je trouve que c'est une
société qui est heureux
finalement beaucoup plus américaine
européennes et qui fait américaine les
hommes de plus en plus
et d'ailleurs
lg les statistiques sur les étudierons
un québécois qui font des échanges à
l'étranger
et la france et l'europe apparaissent
beaucoup moins maintenant comme des
destinations
du rêve de pouvoir
le yoga risque pour le
la francophonie de l'indiquer mettre à
l'abri
ah oui je pense de toute façon
moralement a basculé pour 100 e
pour cent y a plus d'eau dans le fait
que de francophones et pour 100 euros et
je pense qu'il ya un danger réel pour
la francophonie et bien sûr
le voyageur ayant le sentiment que c'est
un c'est un étage québec
particulièrement tournée vers
l'environnement un pays très vert
avec des comportements très écolo à
ce que c'est le cas
je ne sais pas au québec cmq c'est un
rapport à la nature qui est tellement
immédiat
c'est pas le sien rester dans le cadre
c'était tellement partie du mode de vie
numérique de de faire soit du camping
qui a été au départ réel à la
chasse par exemple
c'est un système qui s'empressent pas
c'est juste que c'est
beaucoup plus immédiat est naturelle
paradoxalement pour c'est l'un des pays
qui investit plus argent dans
l'exploitation du gaz de schiste 8 et 9
juillet les nappes phréatiques sens
% et polluer pour beaucoup d'entre-elles
ya les collections de gm après escada a
réduit sans fête entre la richesse des
et des ressources naturelles et parfois
l'exportation qui est fait pour ça que
je me dis que je suis le ju-jitsu pas du
tout certains de ses comportements
écologiques issues des scandales sur
eux
la coupe des arbres pour les pâtes et
papiers pour ses prestations et la
déforestation au final nous
laurent pokou des décennies pour
remplacer par des conifères et du coup
sa lettre
bouleverse complètement à la faune et
la flore
c'est un pays aussi divers que ça non
partante et la rencontre tel n'était
pas le cas ou pas dans les comportements
hébergés à valenciennes
le fait de parler d'eux dans cette
abondance
encourage pas aussi des comportements de
gaspillage ou justement de se concentrer
leurs ressources comme c'est le cas en
chine
alors
mais bon je pense que l'islam financée
par fonds
parce qu il est en ce moment
depuis hier
comme à son origine
lundi ribéry
une raison pour laquelle on a assisté
le
pour compenser cette perte
on ne connaît vraiment ouvert écolo %
maintenant les pratiques au quotidien de
séoul
jean ii
il a certainement incité la nature
c'est l'un des principaux atouts
touristique du tibet avec la forêt
rencontre
à plus de la moitié de la superficie
de l'état c'est l'un des plus grands
réservoirs d'eau potable de la planète
on va en parler avec m anne-caroline du
marié
alors le québec est connu pour
l'immensité de son territoire pour la
richesse de sa nature surtout la la
forêt évoque je crois que la moitié
de la superficie
réservez parcs nationaux non mais je
voudrais savoir en fait qu'elles sont
efficaces qu'elles peuvent découvrir
1 en ce qui concerne h 15 à la nature
qui est du québec
c'est vrai que le québec est connu pour
pour ses grands espaces
c'est vrai qu'ils ont su comme les
américains préservez % et très très
bien toutes et tous ces espaces en
aménagement
en e3 toutes ces réserves de nature en
partie nationale au corrézien phonique
et cetera il faut reconnaître que c'est
c'est quelque chose qui est assez un
travail admirable c'est donc
pour ça et festive mon avis ils vont
tout a été préservé impeccablement
très bien organisée et voilà
parfaitement administrés donc le
spectacle de sa relation d'amour sont
par exemple des baleines
en e
il est très important de québec
l'observation des baleines est devenu
une activité phare
dans dans l'industrie touristique
québécoise quels sont les autres
animaux cd non pièces qu'on avait un
peu des caribous quand on voit la valeur
effectivement les caribous et les
orignaux on peut les voir on peut les
voir en pleine nature
il n'y a pas de la part d'observations
pour organiser on va dire de ces animaux
alors qu'il ya des observations
organisé de baleines et les
observations organisée deux courses
aussi qu'on peut aller voir bourse mois
avant c'est la seule qui se taisent
bourse que l'on peut voir au québec
et alors là ils ne seront pas déçus
sa fille c'est évident que québec est
aussi connu pour la rudesse de ses
divers sanglant 160 jours par an je
crois assister à une tempête
à commencer près par quelques clubs
que sont les habitants que d'affaires
donc les voyages à forfait 16e
alors les vêtements il faut être
cissé abriel et les québécoises ont
l'habitude de gérer ses hivers même
s'il atteint définir il faut il faut
arriver effectivement a passé cet hiver
qui peut durer jusqu'à elle
mais l'homme aujourd'hui dans la
société moderne entre eux le confort
des maisons et isolation thermique les
doudounes high tech pour ce tout le
monde arrive à s'en sortir et les
québécois sont très très bien
équipée pour sarcelles s'adressant
plus capable montrant que je crois un
peu près
faut se préparer en partant au québec
en passant par et certains équipements
et puis euro ni va aussi pour faire un
certain type d'activité qui ne sont
vraiment pas les mêmes que collectif
donc on peut on peut faire du ski de
fond pour cette c1 n'ont pas perdu ce
qui apparemment deux heures de
maureillas las
arrivé à la station mont-tremblant qui
est une petite station et qui accueille
aussi bien des skieurs de fond que des
liens que des skieurs alpins ans pour
l'heure on peut faire des balades la
motoneige ça marche très très bien
avec un réseau qui est assez unique au
monde je crois
alors on peut faire des balades chiens
de traîneau notre activité qui est à
eux ce qui plaît beaucoup
on peut par les balades en raquettes un
brin de la pêche blanche donc comme
pour cette femme a passé la main à la
pêche en fait à travers la glace
d'envoyer les activités ne manquent pas
pourquoi chanter sur le droit à une
scène se marier avec les rivalités de
se marier avec le père
lisez aussi la sortie de la ville
célèbre c'est ce qu'ils font à
l'assassinât en fait à la le roudourou
réapparaît enfin
elle a donc la neige commence à fondre
on doit ces appels au fait où l'on
enseigne les érables pour extraire le
fameux la femme celle en fête et qui
nie qu'il devra prêter aux d'érable
donc on fait chauffer cette scène et
ont la réponse sur de la neige propres
et alors on fait cette saison ce sirop
se transforme un peu en sucette
et c'est ce qu'on appelle la tire
d'érable c'est une coutume qui plantait
des québécoises quick que les laits
les habitants
au plaisir à retrouver chaque année
tous les élus et les habitants se
retrouvent dans les cabanes à sucre
pour fêter cette c'était tirs
merci beaucoup merci à lui
biya la vie la france les richesses
naturelles et l'art des principaux
atouts
d'ici juillet d'agir dans ce rapport aux
100 systèmes économiques comment se
porte le marché du travail
c'est frédéric lefret
office franco-québécois pour la
jeunesse qui ne répond pas
n
grâce à cet appareil photo
après la mecque
le québec était très riche en
ressources naturelles donc sur quoi
repose son économie est-ce que c'est
justement d'exploitation
de ses ressources les richesses
naturelles sont une tentation très
important d'ailleurs
quand vous regardez dans le pays d
europe du québec vous avez trois axes
pro le premier
si tout ce qui concerne
globalement la rochelle la richesse bien
évidemment du sol ensuite vous avez
tout ce qui est
cette nouvelle technologie
quelque chose de très important au
québec eric évidemment le connais par
bombardier
l'aérospatiale c'est quelque chose de
très important
quercia peu près de 17%
le plus pénible au niveau de l'énergie
la spécificité est assez long
d'accord elle a donc été droguées
leclerc
qui est pour cent et quelque chose
d'énorme au québec qui permet pour
cent et bien évidemment d'exporter pour
l'électricité aussi bien d autres
côtés de la province du canada
mais surtout aux etats-unis c'est un des
premiers à des plus gros fournisseurs
pour monde
des extraits cités
et justement les échanges à andorre
nécessité
les échanges commerciaux se font et 5 5
moins que les etats-unis alors
à deux tiers avec les etats-unis la
crise est passé et actuellement pour
les entreprises la québécoise s'est
consolé en moi optique vis à vis des
régions
franco-québécois d'entreprise
ce qu'ont fait systématiquement c'est
qu'on essaye de faire en sorte que les
québécois exporter plus avec l'europe
et pour 100 euros n'a guerre civile et
par ce dernier avéré par la réunion
la crise nous a donné raison
pour cent étant donné que beaucoup
d'entreprises québécoises étudier
avec les industries automobiles
des etats-unis
la crise a fait que malheureusement ça
moins fonctionné et maintenant les
entreprises québécoises se disant on
va rééquilibrer
et on va aller de plus en plus vers
l'europe
et notamment la france dakar justement
ce que voudrait savoir
elle voyage simple comment une aide qui
m'aide a assuré que à la crise ont
survolé et encore plus quand on n'est
pas sortis
pour ce qui est des spécificités alors
nous en sommes on peut dire que québec
là
bien traversé la crise
quand vous voyez qu'aujourd'hui le
québec
et la province qui aura plus de toute
croissance en 2012 du canada
ils vont être à peu près à deux
heures de 2% vous voyez un petit peu ce
que ça fait par rapport à la france
en plus ils ont un système qui leur
permette d'avoir bien fonctionné
d'ailleurs le monde entier vient voir le
fonctionnement des banques canadiennes
tout simplement parce que depuis les
années 80 les banques canadiennes
d'affaires de détail sont séparés
donc à dater du moment les banques
d'affaires ou des problèmes il n'y a eu
aucun impact sur le crédit on est
heureux au point de vue des parties puis
des entreprises au québec en matière
de crise quand vous regardez la
démographie du québec et son activité
économique
huit gardes 2 millions d'habitants
d'ici 2016 un verre de deux millions
d'emplois à pourvoir
ce qui est énorme pour un pays
et donc il a une attirance le québec en
ce moment
notamment les québécois font beaucoup
pour que les francophones et les
français en particulier
puissent venir au québec travailler et
c'est bien son travail
ces migrations travail pour cent des
francophones sont privilégiés
et vraiment dans les francophones france
or justement elaine au travail âgées
elles partent en stage pour l'instant
mais elle n'exclut pas pourquoi passer
ses caisses
d'essayer de donner un easter et à
travailler là-bas à nantes dans le
domaine de la petite enfance pour ce
sera facile devant sa toile alors facile
ça se prépare ça se prépare nous le
type de l'office franco-allemand pour la
jeunesse nous ce qu'on fait on accepte
les jeunes chaque année
à se préparer à travailler au québec
ea sur le domaine de la petite enfance
ils ont de la chance son sur un secteur
porteur
les québécois sont très novateur en
banque ce qui est politique sociale
par exemple ce sont les premiers pour la
petite enfance ce qu'ils vont découvrir
qui ont inventé ce qu'on appelle la
pédiatrie sociale
ça permet dit qu'il avait un enfant à
l'âge de trois quatre ans
mais on décèle quelque chose qui me
convient pas à partir de ce moment-là
il ya toute une équipe
pluridisciplinaire qatari en prêtre
enfants
des parents
de la famille des voisins et des gens
qui habitent autour et elle leur
leitmotiv c'est vraiment qu'on peut
mettre la prévention
est ce que d'autres comportement
d'autres conseils que vous donnez pour
qu'on danse pour bien se comporter dans
une entreprise est finalement bien être
acceptée
alors que le conseil s'est tout
simplement de ne pas avoir peur du
tutoiement
le tutoiement est de rigueur donc ça
s'est très très bien
ça permet de s'intégrer et il ne pas
hésiter à donner et donner des idées
dans toutes les entreprises où on place
des transferts
pour ceux qui vont travailler trois à
douze mois qu'est-ce qu'on voit on voit
tout simplement qu'à chaque fois qu'un
français propose quelque chose
contrairement
un stage dans une entreprise française
les québécois disent marque cello m
au niveau de recrutement ce qui est
privilégiée ça avant tout
vous comptez tensiomètre
c'est-à-dire votre savoir-être
après évidemment on va regarder si
vous avez des compétences techniques
mais si vous avez pas un bon caractère
souhaite pas capable de travailler en
équipe
et d'apporter quelque chose de nouveau
vous êtes moins privilégiés pas
encore permis - les séries les
diplômes
c'est pour ça que nous basons pas nos
exclusion donne des cours de ces années
pour cent des québécoises
pour permettre aux jeunes de mettre en
avant
tout ce qu'ils ont fait en dehors de
leur travail de leur travail
à la solennité pour la personnalité
il souhaite une jeune association si
vous attaquez
ce que les québécois aiment passer
quelqu'un qui soit assez vais pas avoir
que des diplômes
irène loto merci beaucoup freiné à
quatre la série
guido
l'avenir
migaud
en soirée
voir allah dans les bars
vous êtes très partagés à en faire
malgré elle
il arrivait
merci à tous ces faits
hier eric gerets
à la pensée inde préparait
à votre voyage vous amener quelques
petites choses la dernière album de
coeur de pirate blanc note qui va aider
à se réinsérer
l'écossais n'a encore rien à voir et
à sentir les commandes
la traversée du continent - dr michel
tremblay
mélissa cet art
un plasticage 10% roman - 1 7 md créée
en 1913 écart
parce que la conscience collective
québécoise
amusez-vous bien
envoyez-nous est nouvelle
après avoir parlé à sa merci la
remarque
jc - si vous savez quand vous êtes à
préparer votre voyage envoyez-nous vos
destinations envisagées à l'adresse
ils sont variés alice publique
points et faire suite à la nouvelle
donne mondiale et nicolas qui partait en
arrêtant la dernière mission à
bientôt
double